a friendship founded on business
is better than a business founded on a
friendship
there is no other quality so essential
to success of any kind
as the quality of perseverance
it overcomes almost everything
even nature
the impression was gaining ground with
me
that it was a good thing to let the
money be my slave
and not make myself a slave to money
the secret to success
is to do the common things uncommonly
well
good management consists in showing
average people how to do the work of
superior people
how much money does it take to make a
man happy
just one more dollar
you should rather hire a man with
enthusiasm
than a man who knows everything
the success of each
is dependent upon the success of the
other
you should always try to turn every
disaster
into an opportunity
a man has no right to occupy another
man's time unnecessarily
think of giving not as a duty
but as a privilege
a man of words
and not of deeds
is like a garden full of weeds
if your only goal is to become rich
you will never achieve it
success comes from keeping the ears open
and the mouth closed
i would rather earn one percent off a
hundred people's efforts
than 100
of my own efforts
i know nothing is more despicable
and pathetic
than a man who devotes all the hours of
the waking day
to the making of money for money's sake
the only thing which is of lasting
benefit to a man
is that which he does for himself
money which comes to him without effort
on his part
is seldom a benefit
and often a curse
if you want to succeed you should strike
out on new paths
rather than travel the worn paths of
accepted success
don't be afraid to give up the good
to go for the great
go as far as you can see
when you get there
you'll be able to see farther
a man's wealth must be determined by the
relation of his desires and expenditures
to his income
if he feels rich on ten dollars
and has everything else he desires
he really is rich
you should never have ambition to make a
fortune
mere money making should never be your
goal
you have an ambition to build
you should have ways of making money
that other people know nothing of
it is wrong to assume
that men of immense wealth are always
happy
there is no mystery in business success
if you do each day's tasks successfully
and stay faithfully within these natural
operations of commercial laws which i
talk so much about
and keep your head clear
you will come out all right
it is very important to remember that
other people tell you
not so much what you yourself already
know
the poorest man i know
is the man who has nothing but money
he who works all day
has no time to make money
our cup
will truly run over
only after we have sealed the character
cracks
nobody does anything if he can get
anybody else to do it
when work goes out of style we may
expect
to see civilization totter and fall
giving should be entered into
in just the same way as investing
giving is investing
charity is injurious unless it helps the
recipient to become independent of it
singleness of purpose is one of the
chief essentials for success in life
no matter what may be one's aim
the root of all evil is not money
but the lack of money
do not many of us who fail to achieve
big things fail because we lack
concentration
the art of concentrating the mind on the
thing to be done at the proper time
and to the exclusion of everything else
the most important thing for a young man
is to establish credit
a reputation and character
don't work after 50
because money won't let you know
yourself
spend time wisely
then you will be extended
people become poor
because in their youth they set their
priorities wrong
if you are alive
you are already rich
the way to make money
is to buy when blood is running in the
streets
i believe in the dignity of labor
whether with head or hand
that the world owes no man a living
but that it owes every man an
opportunity to make a living
next to doing the right thing
the most important thing is to let
people know you are doing the right
thing
the road to happiness lies in two simple
principles
find what it is that interests you
and that you can do well
and when you find it
put your whole soul into it with every
bit of energy and ambition
and natural ability you have
the ability to deal with people
is as purchasable a commodity as sugar
or coffee
and i will pay more for that ability
than for any other under the sun
i believe that love is the greatest
thing in the world
that it alone
can and will
triumph over might